could you openly and honestly admit that
mr. Corbyn lost labour the election and
you must move the party to the center to
stop Boris Johnson enjoying 10 years as
Prime Minister listen Andy what's your
response well there's no question that
Jeremy came up on the doorstep and
questions of leadership came up on the
doorstep on nearly every door that we
knocked on in the general election and
that wasn't just true in my constituency
and Wigan one of those red wall seats it
was true everywhere that I campaigned
and but it wasn't just that I mean we'd
had four years of nastiness towards
ourselves and each other for a party
that claims to want to build a more
compassionate fairer society that was
really existential the issue of
anti-semitism came up on door after door
after door even in areas where there
wasn't a big Jewish population because
people really didn't like it and they
wanted to see us change it wasn't just
that either brexit came up over and over
again we'd managed to get ourselves into
a position on brexit where leaders
thought we were remain as we're remain
as thought were leaders from right
across this country wherever you were
people felt profoundly disrespected by
who
so who's to blame them for that brexit I
mean you've got the shadow Bret's that
Secretary's standing next to you is he
to blame well it was a disaster it was
an absolute disaster and I think there
is a collective failure of leadership on
brexit that we have to own up to as a
party but let's be honest - this has
been a really long time coming for
decades people in towns like mine and
towns like Jewsbury have been saying
that labor is no longer of or for our
communities I want not to change that's
why I'm standing to be leader of the
Labor Party I don't want to move labor
to the center I think people see the
need for fundamental radical change in
this country but I would like to move
labor to the north
you said you said the brexit policy was
a disaster do Holtz okay start for
William I went out with 44 teams across
44 constituencies in the general
election and all the campaign teams were
talking about what's coming up on the
doors of course they were it was a very
lively conversation and across the
United Kingdom and some of you may have
knocked on doors there was uniformity
there were four things that were coming
up the number one was the leadership the
Labour Party and anybody who was in the
campaign can't say otherwise whether
that was fair or unfair it is secondary
that was the number one issue
I'm afraid brexit came up of course it
came up and I completely accept it came
up but it came up differently in
Dewsbury to the way it came up in
Scotland and that was one of the
difficulties eventually I think I won't
duck that in the slightest the third
thing that came up and this is the teams
that I was with reporting to me and they
were all open about it was the manifest
they was overloaded they had good stuff
in but there was too much it got to a
tipping point where people didn't
believe it and therefore it didn't
matter what was in it because it wasn't
being believed and I'm very sad to say
the fourth thing that was coming up was
anti-semitism and it came up as a values
issue and it came up as a competence
issue so far as BRICS it is concerned
what we were trying to do was to protect
ourselves from what Johnson was going to
do I didn't vote for Boris Johnson's
deal because I thought that it was a
very bad deal and it would end up in a
really bad place now today the white
papers been published and it's obvious
where Johnson's going to go next it's
it's got no deal or nearly no deal
written all over it and it's communities
in Dewsbury and elsewhere they're going
to pay the price and that's that's
that's why I didn't vote for Johnson's
deal because as soon as I saw what he
put on the table I thought it was been
set out today the questions about
Labour's brexit policy do you take
responsibility for the policy actually
brexit secretary that Lisa Nandi has
just described as a disaster I take
responsibility for everything in our
manifesto it was actually a Shadow
Cabinet decision it was actually
decision our whole party a party
conference but I'm not going to shirk
from that but I do there's a there's a
since we're looking at what happens next
leave remain is over so that divide is
not there we've left the EU so whether
you were full remain or leave is
irrelevant but there's a big test coming
up for all of us okay because we had a
problem cuz the question is now Johnson
is heading for no deal or nearly no deal
if we become leader of the Labour Party
will we take him on or we will give in
to it and that's the question we need to
answer okay Kirsten we just said that
the Shadow Cabinet was responsible for
Labour's brexit policy as so on in the
chair cabinet do you see yourselves as
equally responsible look I think we need
to recognize that there were many
reasons as to why we lost this general
election and brexit was one of the key
ones I come from a leave constituency
and I could feel the anger on the
doorstep from my constituents they saw
rose in Parliament playing parliamentary
games they didn't understand why and
they thought we were trying to attempt
to overturn the result of the referendum
and if you were a strong remain
supporter well he didn't think we were
going far enough in having that close
relationship with the European Union
well the sad fact is is that with that
lack of trust in Breck see it took so
many other things down with it and yes
leadership did come up on the doorstep
because we'd had four years of Jeremy
being vilified and attacked by the press
we knew that we weren't trusted on
issues such as anti-semitism and our
handling of that within the party and on
our manifesto the sad thing is is that
despite it being the most transformative
manifesto we've had in a generation with
the right answers to the right questions
that society was facing we didn't
explain ourselves and we didn't have a
message that spoke to communities and
spoke about their aspiration although
look at the worst election result since
1935 and you say that the manifesto was
great I tell you what nobody voted
against having a better quality of life
and we should have explained how the
policies in that manifesto would have
delivered okay but on the question about
should we move to the centre the Tories
are laying a trap for us they try to pay
page themselves as the
anti-establishment party in this general
election we were the party that didn't
listen to our voters or our communities
and we can't fall into that trap and the
only way we avoid that trap is by having
a bold transformative vision of what the
future will look like and when we talk
about left and
to write whatever you like I'll let you
into a little secret those policies
investing in education investing in
infrastructure reindustrialize in huge
parts of the north they weren't
left-wing or vertical okay they were
sensible economic policies that have
been adopted by other countries in the
European Union and if it's good enough
for them it's good enough for us okay
[Applause]